happy Martin Luther King Day reject
nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we gonna
watch I think this might be a just a TV
spot a lot of people were reacting to
yesterday I think the actual trailers
coming out tomorrow
this my news might just be the shorter
version of that yeah before we hop into
this I do want to say thank you to
everyone each and every one of you who
has downloaded the Stardust app and has
followed us there we do thirty second
reaction reviews for films TV shows or
trailers so if you want to get early
access to our opinions and especially on
a bunch of other things that we don't
even cover on YouTube it would be cool
if you get download the app follow us
first it's free to use
so purchase you
silly names and my powers will become
yours
[Music]
I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer please yes you have a location like
on a cliff in a castle ask type things
and water splashing on rocks or
something we will take that that's cute
not a whole lot to go off of there no
just a couple charming moments and some
pretty big scale looking action
sequences well that shot what he
transforms in this is a midair yeah
that's cool I hope we get a whole bunch
of different ways of him transforming
into Shazam yeah watch it cool new ways
to watch him go from little good a big
guy in the old time if he transforms
underwater will he like destroy all the
life under the sea cuz there's that
lightning bolt that strikes you know of
course you get this one moment here that
looks like a Man of Steel fight between
him and dr. Thadeus hair looks like
there's gonna be some destruction I
watched the Shazam animated DC movie it
was like a half hour long but it was
cool it was pretty much what the first
trailer gave me except there was a lot
of leaking it to Superman
like Superman's heavily involved in that
I don't know if that's how it goes in
the comic books early on what he becomes
Shazam he when he is in Shazam for me is
pretty serious okay he wasn't like this
humorous interpretation that we get
right here where he's cracking a lot of
jokes but to me this makes more sense
because it's the mind of a 12 year old
kid or something yeah old Billy's
supposed to be but it is the mind of a
kid so it makes more sense that he was
still behave like a kid who's taking
advantage of the fun superhero Dennis
but I'm kind of curious to know how like
DC fans I know Aquaman is the
highest-grossing DC film right now
especially cuz it's China but I'm
wondering how they're feeling about the
change of marketing especially they've
been doing not just a change in
progression of the film's but the change
of marketing specifically like they're
really honing in on he's not a serious
dark brooding character yeah like they
have to shift that with Aquaman I feel
like Aquaman and this both they have
made a mark in turn away from their
original Grimm's sort of yeah tone
they've infused tons more humour tons
more color well they're more on the nose
here though they're thought out saying
he's not so serious it's no word yeah
Aquaman so had this like epic this is
world devastation stakes right here
where Shazam is like nah he's just he's
just having fun you know I feel like the
next trailer might hint at something a
bit more intense for this movie because
some of the action glimpses we got here
looked a bit higher scale than I was
initially expecting from that first
trailer so I kind of feel like yeah what
they're doing now is still like the same
scale to action they were doing before
so now they're putting more humor
directly into the trailers and directly
into the movies too cuz like Aquaman the
trailers would constantly under cut
themselves with like a dress or like
here's something that's overtly amusing
or overtly light I guess I wonder how
the DCPS overall will respond to that
because I know that some of them have
just not been super excited about the
Marvel s sense of humor they've been
borrowing lately that's true well I
guess maybe it would be a full trailer
especially because now that you're
teasing a little bit more of the actual
fight moments that you're gonna have
with Mark Strong
well the stakes really be you know felt
like as much as I love the first Shazam
trailer and even I even really like this
one too you need to have some some
stakes yeah yeah I mean I'm sure the
David Sandberg will be able to wring
suspense out of things but yeah I'm
curious about that too I guess I guess
will she just save a little bit more
commentary for after the official second
trailer no doubt well before we wrap
this video up I would like to give a
patron today shout out to a man named
totally jumbled TJ how you doing man we
wanted to specifically show you out in
this video because I remember one of the
more recent times when we talked with
you on Google Hangouts we talked with
your wife as well lighten the sexy [ __ ]
and hot why I'm not a [ __ ] she's
bitching not at you though just in
general like Apple in a Twitter storm I
haven't as a woman yesterday so it's
cool that we know that she hates this
interpretation of Shazam and that's why
we wanted to shout both of you out in
this video yeah it represents the other
side of the argument I'm sorry you guys
are being let down
but this is what we need right now some
fun some humor and I'm sorry you two
have none of that ever since you got
that little baby it's all stress all the
time
up in the middle of the night you know
change now bottles burping people laying
them back you need to have some fun in
your life and maybe Shazam can help
maybe changing up Shazam wouldn't make
your life more fun open to it
TJ if you're watching this do not show
your wife is shown oh I'm terrified of
her energy and strength the worst
adaptation of a source material you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us out
on patreon we got TV show reactions Q&A
s music video card love day you become
tragic today yeah